by 8 bricks into the frontcourt Leonard
the black walkers got a clearance light
ranch - [ __ ] and she sends his starters
games gonna have to put up some farms
right let's drop this play 30 of a
possible 34 minutes now the five on the
shot clock
Lopez on the drive
[Applause]
Lopez all the ways he can store [ __ ]
switches off Middleton
[Applause]
be good defensively and then try and get
out and run a playoff for these wax
my closet therapy happy about
[Applause]
can use to attack the basket noise
consol in the game no shot blocker
on fire here to start this fourth period
team concept guys Yanis 21 for his
whistle Kauai
[Music]
this is all because of the Bledsoe tries
he needs to stay in the kitchen of
Leonard welcome have the last
[Applause]
our little geneticist first locos
averaging wider Lowry hesitate with
Lopez on the way he's been shooting
[Applause]
what
[Applause]
joining the paint offensive rebound
black socks and oh yeah
let me gonna pick moves made by the
China manager John horse 36 year old GM
of the Bucks
[Applause]